- Hi everyone.
Thanks for taking some time
from your busy re:Invent schedule
to come and listen to this session.
We're gonna talk today
about grounding GenAI
with enterprise data, working
with AgentCore and Coveo.
I'm Nick Bordeleau, I work at Coveo.
I work in the product relation team.
Looking forward to give
you some information
around grounding on enterprise data.
So the agenda for today,
we're gonna be work,
talking about why
grounding is so important.
A couple of notion to cover there.
Also, a bit of architecture about how
to integrate Coveo with Bedrock.
The secret sauce, no spoiler alert,
is gonna be prompting.
Everything is about
prompting in the LLM world.
And a few next step after
that, if you wanna learn more.
I wanted to start by not bragging,
but I wanna set the stage a bit
so that you understand
who we are, what we do.
Also, give some credibility
so that you should listen
to what I have to say.
We are an enterprise search company.
We've been working with many customers,
helping them get GenAI to production.
This is an example of Dell.
Dell using Coveo to power
multiple of their portal.
If you want to buy a laptop,
if you wanna buy material from them,
it's gonna be powered by Coveo.
If you go and look at the support section,
also it's gonna be also powered by Coveo.
They have real complex product
and they use us to provide answer
to their user when they
try to solve their issues.
Same thing with Nvidia.
Nvidia has all the money in the world.
They could be building that solution.
They decide to partner with Coveo to offer
question answering to their customer
through the Coveo solution.
Intuit decided to integrate Coveo
inside their own application.
So if you're into Intuit, if
you're looking to find how
to work with the product,
if you have questions,
also gonna be Coveo there.
And Vanguard in the financial
and financial services area
is also a big customer.
Coveo, they use Coveo
like all across the board,
internal, external, and that's an example
of their personal investor portal.
If you're looking to get
information around their product,
not investing information,
but information around their product,
that's gonna be provided by Coveo.
So we help our customer go
to production with GenAI,
we build a whole solution,
but we also have option for our customers
if they wanna integrate with a solution
from AWS to be able to
build their own solution.
So what I've been talking
about so far is the left side.
Yeah, left side of that
slide where we do everything.
Basically, we index your
content, we build an index,
we ground the prompt, we build a prompt,
and then we also provide the UI component
for you to be able to deliver that
on whatever portal you wanna deploy it.
We decided to help our customers to offer
the rest of the platform as a retriever
and then offer integration
point with Bedrock,
AgentCore, Q Business,
and also Quick Suite.
And that's what we're gonna
be covering today basically.
How to integrate Coveo into
the second one, into AgentCore.
But it's gonna be pretty
similar if you wanna work
with Quick Suite or
other solution from AWS.
That's a slide I stole from AWS
that they presented a couple of weeks ago.
I thought it was interesting.
I fully agree with what's in there.
Agentic is probably the future
that's gonna be enabled
the LLMs to be fully used
to their full potential.
I was really interested to
see that there's, in any case,
there's always a dependency on data.
If you are working with GenAI,
you need to ground the LLM
based on enterprise data.
You need to ground them so
that they don't hallucinate.
So there's a strong dependency on data.
This is where we come into play.
Same thing for Agentic AI.
There's always a strong
dependency on tools
and data so that these agents
or those model know how to behave
and know where to get fresh information.
So let's jump into the
meat of this presentation.
Why LLM needs to be grounded?
They need to be factually accurate.
So for an LLM to be factually accurate,
you need to provide them some information.
They've been trained on
data that is basically dated
and they don't know
what's true, what's not.
If you're ask them question,
they're gonna answer
and they're gonna basically give them,
give you back the
information that they got in.
If it's not what your brand thinks about,
what should be told to your
customer, they don't care.
They're just gonna give back
the information to the user
on the other side trying
to get information.
If you ground them, it's
now a source of truth
that you're giving to the LLM
and they're gonna be able to provide more,
most accurate information
and be factually accurate.
If you want your LLM to be
also contextually relevant,
you need to ground them.
LLM don't know much about
the users on the other side
of asking the question.
You want to be able to
provide project information,
user history, those kind of things needs
to be added into the prompt.
That can be done by grounding
the LLM to make it easier for you.
Traceability and trust.
When you ground an LLM, you
can now do source attribution.
If you want your users to be
able to trust what they read,
you want them to be able to see
where that information is coming from.
If you don't ground an LLM,
the information is coming
from the LLM itself
and there's no way to trace back
where this information is coming from.
When you are grounding an LLM,
you're basically providing
them the information
that they should be using
to give back an answer.
This is where you can
do source attribution
and then the users can
then navigate those links
and they can validate if
the information is accurate,
that they can gain
confidence on the system.
Dynamic knowledge update.
Another important one.
Basically, LLMs have been trained
on set of data that is fixed on time.
If you wanna be able to
provide them update on data,
you need to provide that
as grounding information.
So maybe the information
that you wanna expose
in that LLM is already
available out there,
is already public, yes,
but it's dated on the last time
the model has been trained.
So you need to be able to
provide grounding information
to those model or for those reasons.
The holy grail of grounding
is to reduce hallucination.
You want LLM to be able to
answer factually with information
that you trust so that it
don't provide false answer
to your customers.
LLMs are really good at lying
and having us believe that,
that the information that
they provide is true.
So by grounding them,
you're able to reduce
the amount of hallucination
that they are doing.
And an enterprise is
just, it's just mandatory.
There's not enough information
about your enterprise
available out there so that the models
don't know about your data.
You need to ground them so
that they are fully accurate.
Now a bit more on what
makes a good retriever.
So a good retriever need to
have a good depth of knowledge.
You need to be able to look
at a large amount of data.
It's fairly easy to build
a VectorDB to be able
to get a small set of data to be able
to ground your model based
on a small set of data.
But what we see is, when
end users these days
is that they go and talk with an LLM,
they ask first question
and then they don't go back to,
in the Google day you were
looking at the results
and then you were navigating that result
and then you were now, you were gone,
you are on your own trying
to find the information.
Within LLM, people go there
and they ask one question, they refine,
they ask a second question.
So you don't know exactly what's the scope
of what they're gonna be looking for.
So you wanna be able
to provide a larger set
of information so that when
you talk with that LLM,
they're always able to get
an answer out of that LLM.
They don't end up in a data dead end
where there's no
information to be retrieved.
Just like the LLM needs to be grounded,
good retriever needs to
be contextually aware.
You want LLM, you want
the retriever to be able
to know about the users in front of you.
You need that information to be able
to personalize the
information being returned
based on who you are, based
on what you have access to,
based on what you've done before.
Retriever need to be able to take
that information into account
and retrieve a set of information
that's gonna be used to ground the LLM
based on who you are, based on
what you're currently trying to do.
But that's extremely important that
that retriever are able
to be contextually aware.
Relevance quality is probably
the most important one here
because you are providing information,
in fact, to the LLM
before the inference time,
the LLM, you're basically telling LLM
just to use his linguistic capacity.
You don't him to use his own information.
You're basically telling
him, answer user question
or decide course of action
based on the information
that I'm providing you at the bottom.
Don't choose anything else.
Use what I'm providing you here.
So if what you're
providing is not relevant,
is not accurate, then you're
gonna provide false sensor
and that's by design.
So relevance quality
is extremely important
when you are working with a retriever.
Execution speed is also important.
Retrieval, the retrieval part
of a RAG pipeline happened
at the first stage basically.
So when you talk with the LLM these days,
if they're not grounded,
the answers are gonna be coming fast.
And then you're used to see
the answer being streamed.
So as the answer is generated,
it's being returned to you
and you can consume that information.
When you are grounding in LLM,
that information is retrieved at first.
So there's a first step
that's gonna be the user basically waiting
on the LLM to start to generate an answer.
So you need that retriever
to be really fast
so that user can start to see the answer
as soon as possible.
Format supported, you
can do multiple thing
with the retriever, you can
do multiple thing with an LLM,
you can do deep research,
you can ask them question
to guide you toward exploration.
You can do multiple things.
The classic way retriever work these days
is by returning chunks of information.
Passages of information
basically are parts
of information that are useful for the LLM
to able to answer the
question is being asked.
But sometime you just want to have links
so that people can go and
can navigate those links
to do further exploration.
Sometime you wanna do deep research
or you want to answer a
really complex question
and you don't need some
passages of a document.
You need the whole document
so that the LLM can look
at the whole information
and make a mind of itself
and answer the full question.
So I think the retriever it that is able
to provide you various
format of information.
It's extremely important as well.
And concise, being concise and precise,
returning the right information
in as the shortest format as possible
will make the job of the LLM easier
because it's easier to consume
smaller more portion of information.
You don't have to decipher
what you've returned.
They already get the right
passage of information
to answer the the questions
and it's also gonna be cheaper for you.
The more information
you put in that prompt,
the more you're gonna have
to pay for those input token.
So if you have a retriever
that is concise and precise,
in the end you're gonna be paying less
for that LLM inference,
although input token are
not the most expensive one.
In the end, it shows up anyway.
We offer a tool set of retriever,
retrieval tool, sorry, we
offer that to MCP quickly.
We have, in that tool set,
we have a passage retrieval.
So we're able to extract
passages from your documents
and retrieve those documents
so you can use them
to ground whatever tools you're trying
to build within that LLM.
We also have an answer generation tool
in that MCP server where if you're looking
to get an answer and use
Coveo more as an agent,
basically, in the
question answering agent,
you can decide to leave out the prompt,
but simply get answer from Coveo as an API
and then provide those answer to your LLM
when you decide that might be specific
to do something a bit more simple
than answering complex question.
We also have search
and document retrieval.
So if you just want to
get a list of results
for users to explore
and do their own things
with the data, we can also offer that.
And also full document retrieval,
as I was saying before,
for a deeper research
and for more complex question,
getting access to full
document, not just passages,
not just stacking passages one to another,
getting the full document,
let's say procedure
to rebuild a complex
engine or stuff like that.
You can get built from Coveo,
making the job of the LLM much easier.
This is a, an architecture that we suggest
to our customer when
they want to get started
to build an agent.
Pretty simple, nothing
groundbreaking in there.
In the middle you have an agent.
That agent obviously use an LLM.
There is long-term and
short-term memory at the top.
So they can know, they can have a session,
they can work in the context
of a few interaction.
You basically have a
conversation with that agent.
That agent is connected via Gateway.
That's a service from AgentCore
to the Coveo MCP server.
And other side, you have all the tools
that've been talking
about are offered there
on the side via an MCP server.
So the Gateway is gonna be
registering those tools.
Now the agent has a set
of tools that he can use
to do whatever job you wanted him to do.
And we're also leveraging
the identity provider
from AgentCore so that actions
that are performed on Coveo are performed
as the user who's dedicated
on the other side.
So if I go, if I try to
ask question to an agent,
if I don't have access
to some specific part
of the information that
is under Coveo index,
those information won't gonna
be coming true to the agent.
So there's no leakage or information.
So that's also an important
part to add in there,
to have some more contextual information
based on who you are, basically.
Secret sauce.
It's a combination of prompt
and MCP description, basically.
You are building an agent,
you are giving him a set of tools.
So you need to be
extremely explicit around
what those tools are,
when to use those tools,
what they're for, how they
work and all these things.
In the end, it's a model
that's gonna be using
those description to decide what to do
and how to use your tools.
So this is a kind of a
meta prompt that we work
with a few customers.
Global directive, who you are,
what's the main job of the agent?
So that's up to you to
decide what you do with it.
But you wanna talk about grounding,
you wanna talk about memory,
you wanna talk about sources.
So there's gonna be grounding available
that's gonna be done with XYZ tools.
So you need to be explicit with that.
Make it clear distinction
also between memory
and fresh information from the retriever.
So it's another source of information.
Memory is also information
much more limited,
but it's another source.
So you need to be
explicit when to use both.
If you want your source to be cited,
you also need to be explicit around that.
So it's a bit like taking
something by the end,
a young child by the end,
but in the end you do it once.
You test it multiple
times, but you do it once
and at some point the agent
become into autonomous
and be able to use those
tools autonomously.
We have some question that go as far
as defining some types of question.
What is coming from memory,
what is coming from retrieval?
So you can go much further,
but if you build
something good at the top,
that's a really good
starting point to be able
to use a retriever in a good way.
The other part is the MCP description.
So you have an agent,
you told 'em how to use,
not how, but you told them
basically when to use the tools,
what to do with these tools.
On the other side, you have an MCP server
that count these tools.
What we provide by
default is pretty simple.
There's a retriever agent that,
which is not a retriever,
but there's a retriever, which is Coveo.
You have tools for search for retrieval,
you have tools for the full document,
but we don't know what you're exposing
in your index on the other side.
So you need to be explicit around
what's gonna be available
through these tools.
So you want to
first use the tool naming standard.
We've see so many confusion
with customer using dot
in the name of the tools.
So avoid dots go with
snake caves, maybe dashes,
but tool naming is quite important.
The most important one is probably
having good description for your tools.
Stick to concise description.
Once again, that's gonna be used
by an LLM on your side.
So the more precise your
tool descriptions are,
the more, the easier
it's gonna be for the LLM
to use those tools properly.
Stick to one two sentence,
front load the information.
If you are, if the tool
is to create a case,
requires authentication,
start with creating a case,
requires authentication
signal, put that secondary
verbs and type of object
that's gonna be retrieving.
So lots of guideline we can provide,
more information around that.
But defining your tool the right way
is gonna make a mile for the difference
for your LLM agent to use them.
And also schema versus description.
When you use an MCP server,
you get a whole schema,
a JSON schema for that MCP server,
which counting description for the tools.
The whole schema is what's
gonna be used at runtime
for the agent on the other
side to call your tools.
So procedure description,
arguments, all the things,
the all the things that are required
to call your tools are gonna be in there
but the only part that
the LLM is gonna use
to basically decide when to use
and what to use as of tools
are gonna be the description.
So they are part of the same bundle,
but they're used for different things.
So make sure that you
provide good description
for your tools.
That's basically what I
had planned for today.
We have a booth around
the Atlassian booth.
If you make the tour
of the Atlassian booth,
you'll find Coveo.
It's a booth 1529.
We also have a AI masterclass series that,
those are webinar, I think.
There's probably one around every
two weeks or every month.
It can be used.
You can use the QR code here
or you can go on coveo.com to find
the latest AI masterclass.
And I have to tell you to go to the app
and fill the survey, actually,
it'll be appreciated if you fill a survey
to know how to improve.
And there's a few more minutes
if people have question,
happy to answer question or
if you want to come talk,
I'm also available.
I'll be at the booth for
the rest of the day as well.
Thank you.